in 3 2 1 fire there's a lot going on
behind the scenes that the audience
doesn't know about our job is to make it
look easy
Jim Souza and his son are out here in
the California desert to train for their
biggest day of the year right now we're
getting ready to stage 400 shows on the
4th of July their family runs one of the
largest fireworks companies in the world
pyro spectaculars by Sousa the sky is
the canvas and fireworks is our paint
all this setup is part of a highly
technical year-long process that's
engineered for a very specific purpose
what we're really trying to do is I'm
always improve the wow factor what can
we do to to get the oohs and the ahhs
from that audience
it starts in this former Air Force
bunker where they store the fireworks
behind a four inch thick steel door
because you know that's a lot of
explosives so what we have in front of
me here is a sample of the different
sizes of shells we have over a thousand
different sizes and varieties here
stored in this facility and alone and
they range in size from from three inch
four five six inch eight inch 10 inch in
diameter and as a rule you can say that
a three inch shell is gonna go times 100
feet or 300 feet into the sky the same
with that 8 inch about eight hundred
feet into the sky and the way they work
is this the computer on command will
ignite this create a spark it'll then
light this fuse down into the bottom of
this aerial shell is about 12 ounces of
black powder and this is the lifting
charge this shell will be placed in a
mortar and this will fire off and launch
it in the sky meanwhile the time fuse is
burned from the outside to the inside
it's lit a bursting charge and that will
open up this shell light all the colored
stars illuminate the sky in red white
blue
inside those shells is a combination of
old and new technology the basic
component of all fireworks is black
powder and that goes back for hundreds
and hundreds of years to make any
firework you really need a fuel and an
oxidizer just like in black powder you
have potassium nitrate and that's the
oxidizer you blend that with charcoal
and sulfur compound that with the right
mixtures you light it and becomes black
powder so you have a fuel and you have
the oxidizers and that's forms the
basics of it now to add some colors to
it then you add different compositions
you could take strontium that will give
you some red barium is gonna give you
green copper blue you have some metals
to it some aluminum magnesium you're
gonna get some twinkles and glitters
with it and then there's the shape the
two basic types we're gonna have a ball
type shell like this which is mostly its
origin comes from Asia and it's going to
be more of a floral shape and it may
have color changing with it the other is
more of the European style that is
cylindrical and in this type they're
gonna have what's called components and
won't be just the stars that we've been
talking about but it may have whistles
and Tour billions and action pieces
going across the sky Souza's family has
been in the fireworks business for more
than a century and they were innovative
out of necessity I can come back to a
date in 1969 in San Francisco where my
father was out there firing a show by
hand with a torch and doing it the way
we did it for years and years in this
case it blew up right next to him right
in in the mortar and that caused serious
injury to him and his partner his
partner lost his hand my dad lost the
mobility in his hand and got a lot of
different burns with that and then in
the hospital that weekend he said from
this day forward we're going to pioneer
electronic firing today the team uses
computers to precisely launch shells in
time to the music during their shows
this is our design software and what we
have is a wav file of the music that
we're going to play in this particular
show we have a script that's moving with
the music and every time that it changes
because the shell going off in the sky
these little triangles are really an
indication of where there is a shell or
a prior Technica fact going off on the
day of any performance there's still a
lot of work to be done by staff
transporting all those fireworks
building mortars and loading the shells
by hand then they'll be connected to a
computer terminal and sent back tested
and stand by to fire the anxiety starts
three minutes before and that's when we
have the countdown we're rolling the
tape and we're sending out this signal
out to the control center we get to the
ten-second countdown 10 9 8 and about
4:00 we've back timed this very first
shell to go off - 4 seconds we can see
that the computer has sent out the
signal the computer has received it it's
lit the fuse it's fired the show on the
sky and we see it's going it's going and
going and on zero boom Joe was happening
this fourth of July another year of work
will come down to just 30 minutes of
pyrotechnics over in a flash it's Susan
says it's worth it I don't think that
there's any competition there are drones
out there there's lasers but nothing can
compete with fireworks fireworks is a
unique language that I have found all
over the world I don't think you can
beat that